What we're leaving,
uh,
10 15,
20 years from now.
You remind me of that.
All of the joke and the philosophy class
where the professor asks the students,
which is worse ignorance,
ignorance or apathy and some poor kid
from the back of the class says,
I don't know and I don't care.
Well,
I think it's an interesting question.
Is there an exciting way that we could
get the young people to this country
aware and their parents?
Because I refuse to believe that parents
have suddenly become cold and
indifferent to their own kids and
grandkids.
Parents,
I think they've been deceived and a
misinformed and [inaudible] and so
forth.
So we have a political system today,
for example,
where the elderly are unbelievably well
represented.
The American Association of Retired
Persons as 38 dues paying member,
38 million dues paying members.
They write more,
they lobby Mar,
they call more.
And by and large,
it's not too unfair to say a lot of
their programs are.
We want more,
even though by any reasonable standard,
as I say,
some of these challenges are
unsustainable.
We can't,
we're not going to be able to meet the
promises that we've made.
So on the one hand,
we have these,
this culture of our ethic of shared
sacrifice,
being kind of a dirty word,
not wanting to give up anything.
We have political organizations who are
dominant in representing one age group
and the young people who are all about
the future or somehow being slipped.
This huge check,
hidden check I might add for our free
lunch and nobody seems to be doing
anything about it.